May God’s peace, mercy, and blessings be upon you. I have returned to you
again
from the WordPress blogging course. I hope, God willing, that you have benefited from the previous lesson
explaining the installation of templates and styles. In the beginning, our blog,
as we thought, was a
date. I added a new template to keep the blog
looking better. Of course, the template is devoid of anything.  Topics
or comments and I uploaded it without problems. Praise be to God. We will
go to the control panel to make
additions, as we see the control panel in front
of us. We will go to Additions, and after that, a new or
new addition from
here, or possible from
here. After entering a new addition, we will go to
upload any new addition that will appear.  In front of us, what we are seeing now,
we will create a frame and add the add-on. Of course, we have not yet downloaded
any add-on. We will find a function for it and we will find a bad add-on. After Arabization, each add-on will have
an explanation of how it can be installed, but for the most part
they all remain exactly the same way. I told you we will explain the
method of adding YouTube video clips.
WordPress is the first thing
I will download. Of course, I downloaded it on my device. Okay, so we
click here and download it with a direct link. After
you download it, you will upload the add-on to this path. Of
course, we knew from the first lesson
and the second lesson how we can upload anything. He told you that it will
go to your site, and after that,
WordPress, and after
that.  Be sure to be there after that, and after that, Smart
YouTube. Ok, the first thing
we do is go to the file manager, as we
remember, how to upload any WordPress file.
After that, beep, as we see, exactly as before, and we will
go here and tell you to upload the add-on
that we downloaded to the device.
When we see where the
Smart YouTube add-on is and we
do this as we see below, it will perform the
uploading process as I told you. Of course it depends
on the speed of
your connection. Okay, so it tells you that it is the
uploader. We will go back and do the uploading process again.
We will find that our add-on is available. So what should we do
after that, sir?  We are going to extract
or
decompress. Success has been decompressed. We create an application and see if
it is available with us in the name of the folder. We can remove this
if we
want to remove it or its relative. If we want, okay, I will remove it. Delete. Ok, he
told you that after you go to the web, the admin
that is the control panel of WordPress. It has been uploaded. We
can go.  On
the add-ons, of course, our control panel. As we see the
existing add-ons, where is the
add-on that we found called Smart
YouTube? We do an
activation process. An add-on has been activated. He told you that after that, go
to the
Appearance side menu boxes
or Smart YouTube. It is in front of us. We can see which
footer it is
and pull the YouTube name.  Very well. We add the clip of
this clip. It will appear in the home page of our blog. We will
go to
YouTube and go down to stop it, of course, so that it does not
work.
We will click on Share. Then we will choose as we see this in front of us so that we will have the code for the code for this clip. The code for the clip. Of course, we have spaces if we...
We want a specific space that we can choose or specify from the custom
space, width and length, so that it is
proportional to the blog. Of course, we can
choose that it runs in
automatic HD. We can choose it. There is no problem. After
that, we take this code, make it a copy, and go to the
side channel squares
and put it
here. Of course, the title of the clip, for example.
The first lesson is to explain WordPress, and we
save it perfectly. Of course, if we want to delete the addition after we have
added it, it is very nice. We go to our blog and make
[music]. What will we find?
As we see, our clip
is of course very large and does not take up
more space than the blog space, because I chose a
large space.  Okay, I want to adjust. What will I do? Go back to
YouTube and watch my clip, me and the
largest space, so you can see whether the space suits
you or not.
Choose a space that is suitable for me. For example, say the least space or the average and we take the
code of course. When I come to automatic,
I take a copy. When I come to automatic, click here.
It remains 640 in 360. It is written here in the code as
if we were
noticing 6 40 and here 360, the high and the white are
fine. This is just for your information. We will go to the
side menu again and go here to the code and
mark it all and delete and add the second. Or you can, of course,
adjust it from here to the length of the space that suits.
With you, we save and
refresh to see the shape of the
perfect, very beautiful. Ok, if we want to put it
above in the part here, for example, or we want to put it
above or put it below. Of course, this varies according to
tastes or the places you want to add
it, or I can put it in
the slider as we see.  Take a place other than the
footer, it will differ according to tastes or
opinions. Okay, of course, if you put it here, a space here
becomes large for it, then it is possible to make it smaller again. Then we open it
and see what size
we want, for example, if it is 150 by
150 or
170, we notice that there is a dash in it or  These two
dashes we must take care
of, for example, 170, and
save it and see how it looks as
small as we want. Of course, this
varies according to tastes
and opinions. Thus, we have finished with the method of
additions. You were with Omar Mohsen. Thank you and sorry
if it took a long time. Don’t forget to write a script for
the channel and like and share so that  Everyone
benefits